قال رئيس الاداره العسكريه الاوكرانيه في
اوديسا ان روسيا شنت ليلا هجومين بطائرات
مسيره من نوع شاهد على البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والحبوب في المنطقه واضف المسؤول
العسكري الاوكراني ان مستودعات ومستودعات
ومخازن الحبوب في احد موانئ الدانوب تضررت
جراء الهجومين وكانت مصادر محليه قد اكدت
لمراسل الجزيره سماع عدويا في جارات قويه
في محيط ميناء اسماعيل جنوب غربي اوكرانيا
على نهر الدانوب
مجددا حاول العدو الروسي مهاجمه البنيه
التحتيه للموانئ الاوكرانيه في منطقه
اوديسا ليله الماضيه يستمر العدو بممارسه
ارهابه والعيب الجوع وفعلي كل ما يمكن
لاخراج اوكرانيا من اسواق الحبوب العالميه
من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم القوات البحريه
الاوكرانيه
صاروخيه تؤمن سواحلها لمسافه 100 ميلا
بحري واضاف المسؤول الاوكراني في مقابله
مع الجزيره انه خارج نطاق المئه ميل فان
لدى البحريه الاوكرانيه ما وصفها بالوسائل
الخاصه بها لاستكمال وتنفيذ كل المهام
المطلوبه منها
القوات البحريه بتنفيذ المهام الموكاله
لها لا يستطيع العدو الاقتراب من سواحلنا
لان المدفعيه تعمل ولدينا مجموعه متنوعه
من الانظمه الصاروخيه تبدا من صواريخ
نبتون الاوكرانيه وتنتهي بالانظمه الغربيه
مثل نظام حرب الذي قدمه لنا الشركاء تغطي
هذه المنظومات 100 ميل من سواحلنا اما
بالنسبه للمناطق التي تقع خارج هذا النطاق
فلدينا وسائلنا الخاصه لاستكمال وتنفيذ كل
المهام الموكله لنا
هذا وقال وزير البنيه التحتيه لاوكراني
سفينه تحمل اسم جوزيف شوت وترفع علمها
انطلقت عبر الممر الانسانيه الذي حددته
كياف خارج اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب لتصبح اول
سفينه تبحر عبر هذا الممر المؤقت الذي
انشئ للسفن المدنيه من والى موانئ البحر
الاسود وقالت وزاره البنيه التحتيه ان
الممر سيستخدم لاجلاء السفن العالقه في
موانئ اوديسا وبيفديني
خلال فتره ما وصفته بالغزو الروسي
اداره امن الدوله الاوكرانيه نشرت مقاطع
فيديو تظهر مقاله انها مسيرات بحريه
اوكرانيه مصنعه محليا يذكر ان رئيس جهاز
امن الدوله الاوكرانيه اكد فيها حديثا
لقناه سي ان ان الامريكيه ان المسيرات
التي هاجمت خلال الفتره الماضيه جسر القرم
والسفينه الهجوميه البرمائيه الروسيه
وناقله للنفط هي من تطوير جهاز الامن
الاوكراني
من جانبها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
تدمير قاعده للمدفعيه الاوكرانيه في منطقه
زبوروجيا باستخدام مسيره روسيه من طراز
لانسيت واشارت لوزاره ان القوات الروسيه
استهدفت ايضا مركزا للمراقبه في اتجاه
بخموت وفرقه للمشاه واوضحت انها صدت اربعه
هجمات للقوات الاوكرانيه في اتجاه ليمن ما
اسفر عن مقتل نحو 70 عنصرا من القوات
الاوكرانيه حسب قولها